let me pull up this story from
timkess.com
palm springs testing guaranteed income
program for transgender and non-binary
residents the program is one of several
in california offering specific groups
of people with subsidized income so let
me get this straight if it comes to the
point where
trans people lgbtq people minorities are
getting subsidized income that just
basically means white people
pay taxes to subsidize
all of the other marginalized groups
that's the end result isn't it
i suppose it rallies everyone pays taxes
taxes but it only benefits one group
that doesn't sound right no they say uh
timcaster.com reports last month the
city council of paul springs voted
unanimously to allocate two hundred
thousand dollars to develop a guaranteed
income pilot program for transgender and
non-binary residents on march 24 the
city council agreed to pay dap health
and queer works to design the program
and apply for state funding
part of the three phases outline the
city report to bring the proposed
project to fruition california has
already made a statewide commitment to
provide 35 million dollars in funding
for guaranteed income pilot programs
like other guaranteed income programs
the pulse palm springs pilot program
would provide direct cash payments to
individuals to spend as they see fit it
is set apart from some financial
assistance programs that come with work
requirements et cetera et cetera i'll
tell you what's going to happen
if you put this money up you're going to
have a whole lot of people being like oh
yeah i'm non-binary sure how much do i
make how much exactly self-government in
california has always been a huge
mistake or at least in the last 40 years
then who should govern it yeah right
like you know 180 years of statehood is
enough i think it probably needs to
return to being a colonial territory
split in half do you agree with that
california benefit from being split in
half i mean it depends on how you split
it right like you you need to carve out
there there's a lot of red californians
right there's probably more
conservatives in california than any
other state because california is so
populated right right so there's
probably you know
60 40 democrat that's 8 million
republicans and we can use those
reinforcements in texas sure or any or
anywhere else in the country and in fact
that's what's happening with a lot of
them are moving i have so many so many
i'm from california originally i have so
many californian friends and
acquaintances who were moving you would
there was a proposal that would take the
uh the western coastline which goes from
like san diego los angeles up to like uh
san francisco and then that would be its
own
state because the rest is red i wouldn't
do that i would want to make it half and
half if i could like split give san
francisco to the north to be the capital
make it half and half if it's too blue
because you have all that farm it's too
much it's two blue states right you have
to take both big montreal it's already
blue state isn't it right you're then
you're creating two new democratic
seminars for no good reason
it's not it's not even about that it's
that you're not solving any problems by
doing it i just don't see how like the
los angeles government can govern the
redwoods makes no sense that's why
it's look
if you cut the state in half you don't
solve any problems
you still have the democrats who agree
with the democrats whether the state is
one or two states you still have
republicans in certain areas being shut
down and uh
for the two and the residents of tulare
for instance tulare county being
oppressed by the democrats in the big
cities and having their water taken away
from them
so if you want to actually solve the
problems and restore people's rights we
tell all the people who live in these
big cities you got to be responsible for
yourself and work out legitimate
agreements for trade with the people who
live in these marginalized communities
but it's fascinating to me that they
come out and constantly say we must
protect the marginalized communities but
the entire structure of california
oppresses the the the uh eastern uh
desert areas southeastern areas and and
i cite to larry specifically because the
state takes their water away from them
dude you take away their surface water
the history of los angeles the the owens
river valley is this place in northern
california fascinating history so
william mulholland who they named drive
after went and he basically got them to
sign over their water rights in the
owens river valley so then he diverted
their river their water yeah l.a
shouldn't exist as it does no it doesn't
it's from outside water sources it
annihilated the lives of all these
farmers in the owens river valley and
then there was a giant flood the dam
broke and all these people died it's a
horrific story and that's that's the
beginning of los angeles
today just terrible it's got beautiful
mountains it's got it's got lush
greenery and redwoods california is a
gorgeous state pg e is running all over
the state all those wires
california fires man they're coming from
pete not all of them pg e they're not
taking care of their power lines so
they're they're falling down and
catching they spent a whole bunch of
months a whole bunch of money on
sustainability and not on like clearing
the lines around like this is not a hard
we've solved this technical problem for
decades it's like pg e just didn't spend
the money on clearing out uh you know
clearing out the forests around the
power lines i want to explain to
everybody how it's going to work under
this progressive utopia
in california i went and visited to
larry county to larry county how we
pronounce it i believe it's got 300 000
residents
they have no voting power
so these poor migrant workers all of a
sudden one day their water dried up in
their wells there was a drought and i
can understand that the farmers in this
county weren't allowed to take surface
water that they had a lot of i remember
driving past these canals full of water
and i asked the farmer like hey you got
water right there and he was oh we can't
touch that
and all the surface water goes right to
the cities because they just they just
take it from us
i'm like how is that protecting
marginalized communities that the
wealthy elites say we get all the water
and you guys go screw yourself we need
to protect the farmers yeah if we had an
electoral vote type system
representational voting in california
the way we do nationwide then tulare
county would have more power and that
would force the urban centers to
negotiate with them as to what they
actually give up instead the urban
centers say there's more of us than
there are views so we get your water
they're at the end of a dying uh nation
and not the united states no the these
these people think cities are the heart
of the country are wrong it's the farms
and you can now learn on the internet as
if you have a city you can get stuff
shipped to you our shipping is so with
drone shipping in the advance of drone
shipping farms are going to become even
more central the fact that bill gates is
buying up all this farmland is very
concerning to me like corporate farmland
we're gonna have to disperse that back
to the people at some point let's just
do it peacefully
let's bring it back to this story and i
just want to mention they are extracting
from the merit and they are giving to
the the unmerited
this this this ubi program and other
programs basically say if you produce we
will take and we will give it to people
for arbitrary reasons
i mean is that not socialism
oh yeah that's that's pure socialism but
it's i mean it's going to be a well
miserable thing it's it's it's it's it's
precursor socialism i guess the prop is
the better way to say it it's like one
of the it's the seeds of socialism it's
the grooming process
so you have you have a farmer who farms
and he makes food and then eventually
they come in and they say we're taking
your farm away from you you elite and
we're giving it to all the people who
work here and all the people who work
here don't know how to farm and then
everyone starves to death
or worse still they're like everyone
melt down your your tools to make pig
iron and then everyone
starves to death i think that's been
done before
yeah
uh
by the soviets hey i got an idea believe
it or not what if we just did that what
if what can we find like a town and just
run someone as mayor and he can just
overtly run on failed socialist soviet
policy just to see how many people are
willing his name was bernie sanders no
but i mean like outright being like we
need to get everybody to melt down their
rakes
and their shovels this is the only
development
does not melt steel beams but but
imagine going to like brunswick maryland
running for mayor and your position is
we should get everyone to melt down
their metal because we need iron for the
war effort
and then they're like what are you doing
it's like i'm just being a socialist
that's what you guys want right you're
socialist or actually i actually you
know we were talking about
if somebody actually did start running
for office in our area and i was like
why why why is that why is that funny
people were like hey we should get
someone that we know to run for mayor
wouldn't that be funny and i'm like
no it would be awesome because we should
be involved in politics and we should be
running for office yeah do you want to
do it well what move out here
no no running out here but run somewhere
run somewhere i mean yeah like why
aren't people being like i'm gonna run
for mayor yeah that's what i wanna in i
live in arlington
so like i would lose john when i moved
to north carolina
run as a democrat who opposes critical
race theory see how well you do right
yeah no one would go digging in my
twitter history
[Laughter]
wait a minute that wasn't me the john
astor went to new york city and then
built astoria he built a city part of
the city and then just named it after
himself like that's the way that's
that's cool because then you know where
everything is and you have control of
like the the layout and stuff like that
you can do it right from there we should
you know we should do we should uh
we mentioned it before we'll make a
coffee shop
called the coffee beanie but then at 7
pm every night the sign flips over and
says ian's palace and then all of like
the counters and everything spin around
and changes into an entirely different
building wouldn't that be cool we're on
the verge of like graphene pipes i don't
know if technology is good enough to
replace copper piping but copper rusts
and then you get copper oxide in your
water it's really bad for you and you're
saying polyvinyl chloride man what do
you mean good old pvc bbc i'm lost
like we're gonna build
pipes if we're gonna build a city from
the ground up i want to avoid copper
piping
i don't know if it's really nasty i mean
in in crosslandia or crossland whatever
i love it what about like a denser uh
metal maybe something uh lead lead
yeah yeah yeah i think led's not a good
idea and then and then after we lay it
we'll complain to the government and
we'll talk about the poor children of of
ian's palace suffering and we got we
need the government to subsidize the
replacement of these pipes that we built
what are you going to do what would you
do at ian's palace first night if i was
hanging out ian's palace it depends what
kind of establishment is this would i
even be there in the first place what
kind of seedy nonsense you got going on
with it you can't do it without your
[ __ ] let me know what's going on
what's going on this place is going to
be g-rated if i'm there i'm into it all
right perfect so what what are we
serving what kind of whiskey well all
right
g-rated g-rated no no i'm not into the
psychedelic drugs caffeine
psychoactive drugs now that's right
those are literal
coffee ian's palace you'd think it was
like a lounge but you'd go in there and
it would be just a bunch of like people
trying talking about graphics we're
trying to figure out how to how to map
inflation like uh if you if you can
redefine the uh the second what is it
the ideal gas law p equals pv equals nrt
pressure equals uh
volume times uh temperature you can then
add some sort of like expansionary uh
variable to that so that you can get
like right now when it when a system
inflates
is anyone listening to me right now i'm
listening right now
it just goes out and in and that's the
ideal gas law explains how to get water
out of a out of a system but it doesn't
explain fusion gesture you're doing the
heat that you're getting in the system
that causes it to expand is causing it
to expand faster which causes more
friction which causes more heat to enter
the system to expand faster and then you
get inflation which is why you have
fusion but people haven't mathematically
written that out yet and someone out
there is going to do it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there